all right um my talk at the table is our
next guest one of the stars of the
acclaimed series succession fans are
anxiously awaiting the premiere of the
fourth and final season this weekend of
course succession follows the
dysfunctional and conniving members of
the Roy family who are fighting for
control of their Global media Empire
actor Alan Ruck has starred in the
series since 2018. he plays conoroy the
oldest of the Roy siblings who's
pursuing a long shot presidential run
watch this
hey
you okay oh yeah yeah um
polling uh
and yeah 10 days out and
nice what are you out now solid still
holding yeah one person
it's just the fear is in these last days
it could get squeezed
squeeze down from one because that's the
lowest number uh you know decimals it
says that's the lowest number yeah
I'm just saying Alan I love that scene
it's a great scene and Alan Ruck is here
joining us now welcome good morning good
morning yeah your chances don't look so
good Mr President Leverage
[Laughter]
that's like a million people I do love
that attitude which is so much on
display in the show um but how do you
feel about the fact that the show is
coming to an end I'm not ready Alan none
of us are well neither am I uh yes I
made friends for life on this show
um
and uh yeah it's bittersweet really
happy to have been a part of this thing
yeah one of the nicest uh
sort of periods of my career absolutely
the best writers I've ever worked with
fabulous cast great directors everything
the designers everything every member of
the cast and crew
has that quality of yes and yes like can
you do this yes and I was thinking about
this other thing and everybody adds
their special touch to it and that's why
the show is so good the use of the
f-bombs too in addition to Great writing
but the way that they use the f-bombs
and the way that they well specifically
Brian Cox but everybody's all right yeah
yeah it's very pervasive but now that is
all also also taking on a life of its
own too that I think is sort of fun to
watch do you yes I do I I don't trust
people that don't curse yeah you know
you don't as long as you have an
expensive vocabulary I think you know
the occasional F-bomb is is highly
approved and if you and if you wield it
well more power to you that's called
good writing uh okay so uh I want to
know if you can share the extent you can
whether you think fans will be satisfied
with the ending which I imagine you know
well at this point I think it's the best
season we've done I know that's that's a
bold statement but I really do think
it's the best season we've done wow and
uh can you say why you think that
without giving away the storyline
probably not no okay yeah I've heard you
say that you've been waiting for a show
like this for 30 years what is it what
were you waiting for and what did you
get it's funny I just had a little
reunion with some folks the other day I
did a pilot 35 years ago called shooter
for another Network and it was about
photojournalists in Vietnam and it was
the same kind of tone it was a drama but
it was wickedly Darkly funny and it
didn't go to series you know and I've
been wanting something like that ever
since and then finally this succession
job just fell into my lap and um so I
got lucky I love that you said you've
made friends for life that you've made
friends for life on this show I have
done on a few things I've done I did a
show years ago called Spin City I made
friends for life Stuart I remember yeah
so all those guys Barry Bostwick Michael
Boatman Richard kind everybody we're
still pals are there I'm sorry oh go
ahead no I got nothing
Alan you always have something this is
always a news guy question but like are
there real-life politicians that you as
an actor looked at and Drew inspiration
from to play uh your character running
for office
Connor is so um sort of divorced from
reality yeah that I mean I mean some
would say there are politicians out
there who also are you know I think I'm
he he's not very current he doesn't have
a lot of current sort of Heroes I think
I mean he Harkens back to Lincoln and
and models himself very much I mean his
fascination with Napoleon yeah yes I
mean nothing's sort of current but but
people from the past he admires greatly
yeah some people remember you from of
course Gail you know where we were going
yeah go ahead
I mean and I I I have such great
memories of that film especially when
you're when Cameron was in Egypt's land
yeah yeah my Cameron go but here's have
you heard this like in film nerd
Community a lot of us believe that
Ferris was not real that Ferris was a
fiction created by Cameron in his mind
to imagine his life the way he would
want to see it have you heard that the
fight club theory yes have you heard
that I have and and whoever came up with
that I hope they got an A on that paper
very clever yeah I don't believe but you
said you have a love-hate relationship
with the film why well I did for a while
because when I was younger there was a
period where I had a really hard time
getting work and uh everybody kept
bringing up Bueller and I thought well
I'm a one-trick pony and that was the
trick you know and that was just like a
period of two years and I was just I
didn't want to hear any more about it
that's tough well it thinks you know how
it is it's up and down right so uh but
then things got better and I know I'm
really pleased that I was a part of
something that people love that yeah I
love the music from I love the music
yeah it I never hit skip the intro
because I love the music any family news
anything going on good in the family
other than how well you're doing yes my
wife Mirey Enos uh has a new show called
lucky Hank on AMC with Bob Odenkirk and
it just debuted last night and that's
awesome two actors in the family and
we're making it work yeah you know
you're making it work very well she's
also extremely talented we're very very
happy for you very happy yeah
congratulations and it wasn't just
Ferris I loved you in Young Guns I loved
you in Spin City and I love you in
success
that's right thanks Alan rock thank you
so so very much uh season four premiere
of succession airs this Sunday on HBO
Max coming up